[MUSIC PLAYING]
BILL CRAWFORD: Please welcome
to Google Ann Arbor Senior Vice
President of Marketing,
Tony Ambroza.
[APPLAUSE]
TONY AMBROZA: Thank you for
the warm welcome, everyone.
I mean, I do know why
you really are here.
We had to bring the
A18s, our famous beanies.
So we're excited to see
all of you sporting it.
I live around Ann Arbor, so I'll
be looking for those beanies
throughout town.
So thank you again for coming.
Before I kick off with
the whole presentation,
I have strategically
placed videos in here
to make sure you all stay
awake, because it is that 1 to 2
o'clock witching
hour after lunch.
But the first one is
really to bring the life,
hopefully for many of you,
the true spirit and essence
of what we're all about.
It's a recent film that
we produced in partnership
with Jason Momoa.
So a few of you may
know who he is--
pretty famous for different
roles and leading parts
he's been able to secure.
And we've been very fortunate
to become close friends with him
over the last 3 and 1/2 years.
He's directed and produced
four of our last commercials,
and he grew up an Iowa kid
and the son of a single mom
and raised by his grandfathers
who were farmers and carpenters
as well.
So I'm going to kick
things off with the film
that we did in partnership
with Jason that really speaks
to the power of
building a legacy
for that next generation.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- We're on stage, buddy.
Ah!
- Yeah!
[GRUNTING]
- Ben Affleck!
Gal Gadot!
Ray Fisher!
Ezra Miller!
And Jason Momoa!
- Ever since I was a little boy,
I always wanted to be a father,
but never in my life did I ever
think that I would be an actor.
I was raised in small
town America, surrounded
by hard work,
cornfields, and pigs.
My uncles and grandfather
were the hunters and builders
of the Midwest.
I was raised by a
strong single mother.
My mom's an artist in every way.
She's a painter, a photographer.
She's a wanderer, always
searching, always seeing.
I guess you could say
my mom gave me her eyes.
My mom introduced me to
skateboarding and rock
climbing, and I absolutely
love her for that.
Skateboarding-- it gave
birth to a style for me.
It wasn't just the skating.
It was the music.
It was the crew,
the underground.
Architecture was
forever changed.
You wouldn't believe how much
fun you could have on a curve.
And climbing-- it made me
face my fears, my doubts,
explore the impossibles,
problem solve through movement.
I learned to trust my
hands, find my feet.
I found balance and
I found my passion.
I wanted to see
the world climbing.
I craved the road to the wild.
I wanted to get
out, explore it all.
Camping, fires, playing
music, telling stories,
living in the dirt, eating
crackers and sardines.
I was a dirt bag.
There was not a
care in the world.
I packed up my life.
I put it on my back,
free to wander everywhere
from Tibet, France, Italy,
Japan, everywhere USA.
My travels made me
a student of life.
Somehow that path led
me to a crossroads,
and at the end of that
road acting cornered me.
She seduced me.
For an anxious young
man, it finally
allowed me to be anything
that I wanted to be.
The wanderlust gave way
to direction and purpose.
I could be a barbarian
or a bartender.
I could be a savage [INAUDIBLE]
or the King of Atlantis.
19 years I've been doing this.
I'm an actor.
I'm a director.
I write and I produce.
I found my path.
I'm a craftsman.
My craft is storytelling.
And then it happened.
She came, my muse, the love of
my life, my partner in crime.
I fell stupid, crazy,
madly in love with her.
My wife gave me three
beautiful, feral kids--
Zozo-Bear, Lola-Bear,
my lovey, and the Wolf.
And with them, my dreams
finally came true.
I'm a father.
I found my place, my home.
And like any father,
we want our children
to see us doing what we love.
But now, my passion
for storytelling
pulls me away for
long periods of time.
And that scares me.
The nomadic lifestyle
that once inspired me now
takes me away from the
things that I love most.
My [INAUDIBLE], my family.
I'm afraid of what
I'm going to miss--
the laughs, the cries, being
able to help them, teach them.
I don't want to
miss those moments.
If I think about it, I only have
five more years, five summers,
and I'm not the center
of their universe.
I decided to
surround my children
with who I am, with music,
painting, all my art forms.
Because if I teach
them to skate,
then they can surf or snowboard.
Ultimate balance, bold
and brave in any terrain.
And if I teach
them to climb, then
they can push themselves
to the limits,
gracefully move
through fear and doubt,
to learn respect for
our natural resources.
Because if they can admire
nature's truest colors,
they can begin to see
the beauty in all things,
to be aware of
those inconspicuous
and overlooked details of life.
I want to give them my eyes.
They will know art.
They'll paint.
They'll sculpt.
They'll understand light and
darkness and composition,
find their soul, and that's
where the music lies, the soul.
I teach them to play because if
they can play, they can sing.
And if they can sing,
then they can dance.
And when you dance,
you celebrate.
It is all connected.
And these lessons will teach
them expression of self.
And if I build it,
then I can teach them
hard work, dedication,
integrity, and moral code.
Now every time my
children play, they
can feel that their papa
is always with them.
Since the moment I left my
mother's house to the moment
that I built a
home with my wife,
from the ultimate highs to
the lows that brought me
to my knees, there has been one
constant, something that stayed
with me through all of this.
Like a home on the road, a
comfort disguised as armor.
I see it every time
that I look down
at these tattered, old
pants in my battlefield.
From the paint to the stitches,
every scratch, ding, laugh,
and cry is recorded
in these pants.
Every mark is a memory.
Every tear adds up to the
life I always wanted to live.
Everything I am
is in these pants,
and there will come a
day when I'll be gone.
And my children and
my grandchildren,
they will find these beat up
old Carhartts in a dusty corner
somewhere.
And they will know this
is the canvas of my life.
[END PLAYBACK]
TONY AMBROZA: That's a
story that was authentically
inspired by the fact
that he absolutely
lives in those pants.
And all the time, he's wanted
to tell a story about them,
and it morphed through the
relationship we had with him
into being really a story
about the legacy he wants
to leave for his kids,
the idea that he doesn't
want his kids to just know
him as this crazy actor
and superhero.
He wants to teach them
the responsibility.
He wants to teach them to
enjoy making and creating.
He doesn't want them to grow
up in this crazy Hollywood
bubble, where they're out
of touch with reality.
And the coolest part
of all was he gave us
the opportunity and
the platform to tell
a story that our
consumer has been sending
to Carhartt for over 100 years.
We have pants, bibs,
coats framed on our walls
with letters written
by the people
who say often that they had
to return it to the maker
because they couldn't
dare to throw it away.
And usually it's
because the wife
forced them to get rid of
it along the way as well.
And so it was awesome to have
a partner in Jason Momoa, who
could authentically
tell the story, which
is a story that our hardworking
consumers have been telling
for generations.
And being that we're
a family-run business,
founded by a person by the name
of Hamilton Carhartt in 1889
here in Michigan-- for
those of you who don't know,
we are local--
it's a pretty
powerful opportunity
to be a part of a company
that's still owned and operated
by the founding family.
And we still are guided
by this man's principles
and his vision and his beliefs.
Long before anybody
ever really focused
on the story behind the
garment, he was telling it.
Now it's commonplace.
Everybody wants to
know the deeper story.
They want to see the whole
story behind the brand
they believe in.
While he was communicating and
sharing this point of view,
when, for instance, child labor
was a big issue in the clothing
industry, he was taking
a stand against it.
He was making product
up to a standard
for people who did blue
collar trades and work, who
traditionally wore rags that
were stitched together and sewn
by wives or mothers.
He said, there's got
to be a better garment.
There has to be a
better way to make it.
These people should have
hard, rugged clothing
that works for the job.
So long before we had
this cool athleisure trend
where everybody's
running around in Nike
or Under Armour or Lululemon
or any other brand,
he was making purpose-built
product for folks
that most people have
ignored for decades.
He cared when others didn't.
And these are still the
values that we live by today.
A lot of these values,
people are like, well,
sounds like a
millennial mindset study
that somebody had to
come up with, right?
And I just laugh about
it, because whenever I'm
in those meetings I'm like--
because I'm an X'er.
I don't know if there
are any X'ers in here.
Probably most folks
are millennials.
Oh, a few.
Thank you.
It's good to see a few
X'ers, because we're
the forgotten generation
or the skipped over one.
You've got the big boomers
and the big millennials.
But I always am like--
I'm kind of mad.
They are like,
well, millennials,
they love authentic brand.
I'm like, did X'ers-- were
we all about fake ones?
Like, why is this
such a big insight?
I don't get it.
But this is our founder,
Hamilton Carhartt.
And we still see it now today.
I mean, these are pictures
people send to us.
I have had the great
pleasure to learn and work
with really smart people at
big brands that a lot of people
really want to talk about
all the time on the news.
I didn't get things like this--
never.
I mean, never.
I can guarantee you.
And when their sneakers wore
out or their base layers started
get stinky, like everybody knows
that polyester stuff can do,
they didn't mail it
back to us unless they
wanted a replacement.
And that's what we have
here, which is incredible.
In building off of what you
just saw from Jason Momoa--
I mean, this is
one of the letters.
I always like to bring this one
out, because those overalls--
I mean, this is
one stingy farmer.
But if any of you ever grew
up in a farming family,
you recognize the value
of money and their ability
to make something last.
And if you can't
read the fine print,
the simple story
here is these bibs
outlived his wife, who
mended them for years.
They outlived his
neighbor who decided
to start mending them for him.
So he finally was
like, well, I guess
I got to send them back and
get some new ones finally.
But it's just that
incredible relationship
that happens with
people and the product
that they wear because of
all the things they do in it.
And this has guided
us on a mission
that that really is still a
continuation of our founder
Hamilton, with
Mark Valade, who's
the fourth generation family
member and CEO still today.
And that is, "We exist to create
and build enduring products
to serve and protect
hardworking people."
Now, probably a
few people, though,
like Simon Sinek readers
or viewers or protagonists,
antagonists, I'm sure,
somewhere along the line--
but if you think
about it, it is rooted
in a simple why
for Carhartt that
was started with Hamilton, which
is the belief in hard work.
Hamilton Carhartt had
a quote, and I have
to read it from my notes here.
"Work is a thing--
good, earnest,
honest hard work in
the right direction,
everlastingly, persistently,
continuously work.
Making good is merely a matter
of exerting sufficient energy."
Certainly the prose of the
day was a little different
than what we have today,
but the simple fact is this.
He appreciated hard work, and
that's what we still do today.
And it doesn't have to be
in the form of somebody
swinging a giant pick axe
or sledge hammer for us
to appreciate it as well.
We appreciate the hard
work of a Jason Momoa
and the lifestyle he leads.
And that's who we invite into
this brand for the values
we stand for.
So I often hear
how this brand is
being embraced by
folks who typically
wouldn't be seen wearing it
over the last five or six years.
That's great.
That's really good, but
we're not changing our values
and we're not changing
who we are all about.
But we're certainly willing
to open up the umbrella
as we share the story of
what Carhartt stands for.
Now, why has all this happened?
I mean, some folks have asked
over the last few years.
You start to see
Carhartt more and more.
Well, some of it is we have
great partners like, downtown,
Home and garden who sold
a beautiful dog chore
coat down there that's
probably being worn.
It's nice to have partners,
because your retailers are
a big part of this story.
When I had the opportunity
to come back home--
I grew up in the Midwest.
I grew up in Ohio,
two hours away.
Big fan of the Lions, the
Tigers, and the Red Wings.
And my grandfathers
were blue collar.
They worked in
industry, machine shops.
They wore bibs.
They had the metal lunch pails.
I'll never forget that.
My parents were the first
generation in their family
to actually get
a college degree,
and like most families of the
day, they went into teaching.
Because that was
really the profession
that they knew to
pursue afterwards.
And I grew up with this.
I did construction jobs.
And so the opportunity
to be a part of a brand
like this was amazing.
But the first
thing we did was we
were like, we have to spend
time with our consumer.
Who are these people?
What makes them special?
Because I went from having an
opportunity to sell something
that more people seemed
to want to fight about--
outside of politics, but
I'm not touching that now--
and that is your
favorite sports team.
Living in Ann
Arbor, there's a lot
of conversation around
that at the college level.
If you're in Europe,
try arguing over
your favorite football club or
soccer club, as you may know.
There are families that
are divided and never
talk to each other again
because of these feuds.
That's a passion.
For work, that's a four letter
word that most people are
happy to forget about the
moment they're done with it.
So it's hard to
market and inspire
through that, unless you really
understand why they do it.
And that's what we found was,
wow, they have stories to tell.
They have a lot of stories to
tell-- really interesting ones.
And what we started
to learn more and more
is they believe in this
notion that by working,
you earn the ability
to build a better life.
They believe that making
something with your hands
is far greater than
sitting in a room,
like I'm sitting in today.
Because what I get to say I made
today was a really neat keynote
presentation that hopefully
kept you awake for an hour.
So that's what I'll
tell my kids today
when I see them this evening.
What did you do today, dad?
Well, that's what I did today.
What they value is the ability
to say at the end of their day,
they made something or
they made many things.
Or they built a building,
and that building
will forever be something
they can identify with.
And we heard that
over and over again.
They like to make beer.
Thank God they do.
I love craft beer, and I
love being in Michigan.
But that's somebody
who's a maker,
and we appreciate those folks.
And we recognize
something early on, too.
They said something
that I immediately
just kind of jumped out of
my seat when I heard that.
They think with their hands.
So in a company
like Google, it's
interesting to share
that perspective,
because some of the
brightest minds on the planet
all work at Google.
I hear about it from my friends.
I went to college
in New York City.
Investment banks were scooping
up all the mines then.
Now my buddy who is a
partner at B of A says,
yeah, Google takes
all the best ones now.
And it's true.
But imagine, though,
how good are your hands?
Mine aren't that good.
My hands can't really
make very much.
They know how to type.
They're pretty good at that.
My wife will remind
you of all the jobs
that I try to take on at home
and how poorly I do with those.
And then I give up, and I hire
somebody who actually knows
how to think with their hands.
But it's an appreciation
for that fact,
and that's a powerful
appreciation.
And we spent a lot
of time with them.
We have a team right now
who's been on the road,
God bless them,
for over 25 days,
shooting and capturing film
and photography and story
after story that
we're going to bring
to life this fall in "Holiday."
They were just in
the upper peninsula
with "Outside" magazine.
Because what we
found is if you're
a brand that actually tells
really interesting stories,
you don't have to
pay to tell them.
That was the whole
Jason Momoa film.
We're over 70 million
impressions and growing,
and that 8 and 1/2 minute
film blew away all the rules.
But let me tell you, he
was not going to change it.
You can negotiate with
Khal Drago all you want.
We didn't.
[LAUGHTER]
And the view rate is crazy.
Full view rate is crazy.
And you guys, I know, can run
all of the stats on YouTube,
but we ran it across
all platforms, too.
But you would see
it's breaking rules.
When you have an interesting,
real, meaningful story,
people want to cover it.
Editors want to write about it.
So we're up there with
"Outside" magazine in the U.P.,
telling stories about some of
the ski mountains up in that--
what is it-- the horn of
the U.P. Pretty amazing
when you can do that.
But it's how you break
through, because we
don't have a Ford Motor
Company budget when
it comes to advertising.
So our goal is we need to
tell stories that are actually
interesting and inspiring--
not that they don't.
But we really have
to break through.
So we spent a lot
of time with them.
We start to understand
their personas.
And we've understood one
thing loud and clear,
that the Carhartt isn't just
an outdoor outerwear brand
that you wear when it's cold.
It epitomizes an outdoor
orientation towards life
that's year round.
They don't just go outside.
We don't just go outside when
it's cold out with Carhartt.
We go outside all year long.
And it's not just for men,
contrary to popular belief.
But we have a long
way to go, because we
have hundred and some
years being for men,
even though through the years we
outfitted Rosie the Riveter, lo
and behold.
And we've done things
with women historically.
We've had a women's
line now for about--
I've got a few folks
here from work--
10 years?
Lindy?
AUDIENCE: 2007.
TONY AMBROZA: 2007.
So 10 years.
10 years.
And we're going to
be celebrating women
in a slightly bigger
way this year.
We've got a few interesting
stories we want to tell,
and we're going to
bring those to life.
Because we always hear after
every video or commercial we
run or piece of advertising
from a lot of women who say,
hey, I'm a welder.
Why won't you tell my story?
I work just as hard,
and I do a better job.
And we're like, we're not
here to say you don't.
Our problem is, first and
foremost with women's product,
it's not readily available
outside of a few destinations
online and a few stores
brick and mortar.
So thank God for Google, because
you can help them find us now.
And that's one of the
big opportunities.
A lot of people
keep saying, too,
what are you doing around
the millennial, millennial,
millennials?
What are we doing?
We're just being who
we are, and we're
celebrating craft
and making and doing,
which just happens to coincide
with what that mindset cares
about.
And that's what we're doing,
but we're being who we are.
We're not trying to
be a different company
by any stretch.
We also have a fantastically
growing opportunity
with the Hispanic
consumer and their growing
presence in America
and how that's
changing the face of hard work.
We're not here to be exclusive.
Hard work is hard
work, and that's
what we're for, no matter what
the rules of engagement are.
And that's something
that we are spending
more and more time, better
understanding, and building
upon as well.
But we also know it can't be
just about work all the time.
If there's one thing that
we like to joke about,
it is beer, barbecues,
beef, and buddies--
the four B's, the
post-work activities--
and really capturing
that in their lives.
So we spent a lot of time,
and we've got personas.
We can sit down with your team,
but I know your team has them.
We have four personas
that we really
focus on and build around,
and those are the four
we think about all the time.
Because like our
founder, we believe
in a legacy of hard work.
And really, we're embracing
this to get people to recognize
that we're not just
for the person who
swings the sledgehammer.
So all of you are going
to have a nice A18.
But the idea here is
you shouldn't feel, oh,
I'm not really like--
I'm not the Carhartt
guy or girl.
Well, you can be.
Depends on your mindset.
Quite honestly, it really does.
And that's what we're shifting
a little bit, not just
that brand that makes workwear.
It's the brand that
stands for hard work
and hardworking people.
It's a little shift,
not a big one.
And then how do you make work
interesting and cool and fun?
We go to really interesting
places, rugged corners
of the earth, we
call them, where
folks rely on Carhartt
to get the job done
and sometimes survive.
Makes work a little more
heroic, more interesting,
but we also spent a lot of time
with them camping, fishing,
and hiking and hunting.
Because we know that that
is an absolute passion
place for them
throughout the year.
But when we think about these
activities, like hunting,
for instance, it's not about--
a lot of people, it's like
the trophy on the wall.
That's not what we
hear all the time.
It's not it at all.
It's the time you get to
spend with family and friends
and the traditions
that are created,
and that's what makes
it so meaningful.
And that's what makes it
exciting for folks, who really
understand that, again,
it's not about the trophy;
it's about the experience.
And there's another buzz word.
We're in the experience
economy, and everyone's
spending money on experiences.
And you see all of these.
It's like, ding, ding, ding,
business buzzword bingo.
But in the end, we're
experience-based brand,
because our product is
purpose-built for people
who do things.
They don't sit on couches and
watch the Discovery Channel
to dream about a lifestyle.
They live that lifestyle.
And I guess the
goal is, how can we
inspire others to do the same?
You may be a
weekend warrior now.
Great.
Pick up a hobby.
Pick up a craft.
That would be success
for us if we're
able to do that as a brand.
Because we know, too,
that sometimes the best
meals aren't in a restaurant.
Get outside.
Enjoy it.
This is actually a guy from--
he's the chef and owner
of the Grange restaurant, if
you know Brandon here locally.
Great guy, great
partner, farm to table.
We love to work with
him on a lot of things.
We do a lot of things
locally with friends
that we've built up and
developed relationships
with through work
and gotten to know.
So how do we outwork them all?
In a simple sense,
we start with you've
got to have empathy
for one key area.
You have to remember.
Typical household income
of that core demographic,
not the broader
sense but the core,
is about $55,000 to $60,000.
So credit card limits?
$1,000, maybe $2,000.
So one of the things
that we focus on,
because I'm responsible for our
direct to consumer business,
too--
my gosh, if they
have a return, they
need that return
credited quickly.
$150 order is a lot, and it
matters and they value it.
They value those dollars.
To get them to spend
$150 on Carhartt
traditionally ends
up being a Christmas
purchase or a birthday purchase
or something else significant.
You have to empathize with that.
You have to remember
that farmer we talked
about and the frugality
of it and really, really
understand, then, that if
they're going to do it,
you live up to it and you
deliver on that promise.
And if we fail for some
reason with our product,
we always, always take
it back, and we always
make good on that promise.
We absolutely believe in
inspiring a way of life.
It's what we live for.
That's one of the things that
makes this job so awesome,
is because we can do that.
And we have an owner who
believes in that way of life.
His family's believed
in it since the founder.
And we look at it
through their passions
and live it through
their passions
all the time with emotional,
authentic, original stories.
And people always go, why?
Well, there's a
part of your brain
that causes people
to love people.
It also causes you to love
that dog and love brands,
and the best brands get that.
You can't explain that, though,
with a spreadsheet sometimes
in meetings, outside
of some studies that
talk about people and
their connectedness
or their love of brand.
So you can do that.
And what they found
through the years
is that that has the
closest correlation
to revenue over loyalty.
Your love of a brand
has a higher correlation
to revenue than loyalty,
and it means something.
And it's important
in this day and age.
And so that's one of
the reasons we really
focus on that, because we
also want to be top of mind.
How do I remain top of mind?
Because I've seen
all your stats.
It drives me nuts.
Most Google searches don't
start with a brand in mind.
It's like, oh, God.
So they just do coats?
That's horrible.
[LAUGHTER]
I want you to do Carhartt coats.
Because if you
look at coats, you
might see a better deal
from somebody else,
but that happens.
So you have to be emotionally
engaged and connected,
and we have to broaden our
reach in order to do that.
So build trust and loyalty.
These are our three
newest consumer profiles
we've identified today--
Chris, who has that millennial
mindset, working in the trades,
typically learning
their way through;
Samantha, more of an X'er on
the female end of the spectrum;
and then David Garcia,
Hispanic profile,
English-speaking, second
generation, living basically
an All-American style of
life, but certainly very,
very tied to the traditions
of where he and his family
come from.
So those are the three new ones.
Then we have a Mike consumer
that we identify with,
and he's the
traditional over-45 guy
that most people
recognize with Carhartt.
So along the way,
we're not saying we're
ignoring him by any stretch.
He's the most loyal,
spending the most right now,
because he has the
most money to spend.
But what we are seeing is as
we shift our messaging in reach
and target, we're going after
these folks first and foremost.
Mike continues to overhear it,
and he's not seeing anything
with this brand that would freak
him out, until, wait a minute,
what happened to my Carhartt?
You guys really
help us with this.
We have a saying, "Are
we doing everything
possible to make it easy
for hardworking people
to choose Carhartt?"
So that's what
guides our actions.
That's what guides our
effort, and our goal
is to do that all year long.
We have a big challenge, though.
We do not sell our
product in the number
one places they like to
shop, outside of one,
which is a competitor of
yours, Amazon, slightly.
That is the only place we are.
That is a dominant destination
for shoppers today,
and they're just
building apparel
as a destination
choice for them.
We're not in Wal-Mart.
We're not in Target.
We're not in Kohl's.
We're not JC Penney
and Sears, thank God.
You can delete that later.
But we're not in these places
where the bulk of our clothing
is bought.
All the studies tell us that.
Those are purposeful
choices that we make--
not because we want
to make our life
difficult for the consumer,
but because of the way
we believe in running our
business and running the brand.
And they just don't match
up with our beliefs today.
So what that means is we're
not always easy and accessible.
And in a
convenience-driven world--
I was just saying
this the other day,
and I mentioned it at lunch.
We're in an age of
brands, because retailers
are going through an
incredibly difficult time.
For those of you working
with retailers right now,
they are really challenged.
If you have not invested
in the web, it's too late.
And you probably don't
have the capital to do it,
because it's all sunk
in a bunch of stores
that are underperforming.
And so you have to figure out
how to get out of those stores.
And we've had meetings
with some retailers who
will go unnamed who
are very longstanding
partners of ours, who
have been like, you
know this internet thing?
I just still can't
figure it out.
And literally that's what's
come out of their mouth.
And you just look at them.
You go, oh, God.
I don't know what to tell
you other than you are not
on the radar of the
next generation.
You may have your current,
but the next generation
doesn't even know you exist.
Because you're not a
part of that journey.
And unfortunately, it's
too many retailers,
and they don't even
know where to start.
So if there's ever an
opportunity for business
for you guys, it's
figuring that out for them,
because they can't do it.
They flat out can't.
And we need them to by and
large, because ultimately it
will define how many
square feet per person
we have from a
retail perspective
and whether or not the 20--
I think we're at, like, 20 and
the UK and Europe is at, like,
five.
So we forex every
other country when
it comes to how much retail
we have dedicated per person.
We've over-retailed
this country,
so it's going to decline.
But we would still like there
to be some retail stores around,
please.
70% of people still say they'd
rather buy clothing in a store,
because they like to try it on.
They like to feel it.
They like to make sure that
fit is what it says it is.
They don't want to deal
with the hassle of returns.
Number one complaint
still with our consumer--
what a nightmare.
And what's odd is rather than
return it to us, a lot of them
say they'd rather just sell
it on Craigslist or on eBay.
And I'm like, you
still have to ship it.
You know?
But that's what they say.
I don't know why.
So that's one of our
key areas of focus,
because we really
believe in this idea
that we are out of the
disruptor phase of marketing.
It is not about disrupting.
It's about enabling.
How are we enabling
and empowering
that path to purchase?
And again, you guys play
a big, big part in this.
And that's the focus
all the time as a team,
over and over again.
Because it's a challenge
inside our walls.
We have too many silos.
Every single day within
marketing and other worlds,
it's like, guys, this is not
about us; this is about them.
And we are in service
to their journey.
We're in service to their
ability to choose us,
because that's what's going
to keep the lights on and keep
the legacy alive for the fifth
generation of Carhartt that's
already in the business,
learning the business today.
We have all three kids
working in the business
right now, which is awesome.
And we're always measuring
and we're always learning,
and we're always looking
at it again and again
and say, how can we get better.
What else can we get
out of their way?
What else is getting
in there blocking them
from making the right choice?
And you guys, again, provide a
lot of great metrics on this.
Traditionally, I've
always enjoyed--
and I'm just going
to make one plug--
I haven't seen the Q4 results.
Are those in yet?
Because I always love the
Q4 graph that shows search
and how we did and what's
going on, because that
gives us an idea.
AUDIENCE: They do.
TONY AMBROZA: Beautiful.
So we're always measuring.
So another video to kind of wrap
this all up for you guys here,
and then I've got
just a quick breakdown
of how we look at things from
a media perspective as well.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[ROCK MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
Quick overview.
So just to let you
know what we're up to,
we're going to continue a
story we started last year,
which is celebrating the
future through our heritage
and our founder and
his guiding principles.
We're in it a long time.
We've been making new
products, introducing
a lot more products.
We're overcoming
the stigma that used
to be that a new product from
Carhartt was a new color.
So, no, we're launching
a lot of new products,
because we really want to
be around and relevant.
And we're committed
and dedicated
to making that happen,
so that folks just
don't reach for their Carhartt
when the mercury drops.
We want to be that
year-round brand.
And I'm just showing this to say
we are dedicated from a brand
calendar.
We're constantly executing
content, storytelling,
and messaging to be relevant
and top of mind as often
as our dollar will allow us to
be across multiple channels.
And we break it
down in three ways,
and we do this because my
paid bucket is not big enough
to do it any other way.
My owned and earned are just
as important to us as our paid,
and so that's how we
think about things.
Because I cannot beat the
competition by just outspending
the competition.
And really, the team is
really focused on this.
So in the own bucket,
just a few examples.
Our website-- we look at this
as the front door to the brand.
And we have a lot
of work to do still,
but we've made tremendous
progress over the last three
years.
I see the doggone Google
speed analysis you send to us.
I know it.
We're meeting with our agencies.
We want to make it
faster for mobile.
We know for 3G it's too slow.
[LAUGHTER]
So we get it.
An my CIO, though, says,
we just need an app.
I'm like, OK, we
need an app, but what
about for all the other people
who don't want to have the app?
So we're working on it.
We launched our store, our
flagship store, in Detroit.
Everyone said, what on
earth were you doing
putting a store in Midtown?
We look kind of
smart now, thank God.
I mean, it's doing
really, really well.
We have a nice billboard
there on the side,
and it does a great
job of letting
people know that we're there
in Detroit and a lot of pride.
And it's been in
a lot of videos,
really commemorating their
pride and return of Detroit.
And that's the interior
as you walk in.
We view that as own, though.
Every person who walks
in the retail stores we
own and operate is having
a Carhartt experience
we directly deliver.
That is a powerful
owned opportunity just
from a marketing standpoint,
let alone a selling standpoint.
If we leave them with a
great experience of the brand
and the types of people that
work there, that's a win.
Now, granted, we'd like
them to buy stuff, too,
because we need
to pay the bills.
But every person
who walks through
gets a better sense
of who we are.
They recognize that we're not
just brown duck bibs and coats.
They're like, oh, my God,
we hear it all the time.
Wow, this is Carhartt?
You make all this stuff?
We're like, yeah, we do.
Men's Journal.
And really what
we're looking at--
I think I skipped a slide.
Well, I'm going to skip forward.
Earned.
There we go.
I'll go back and forth.
We launched a beer to celebrate
our 125th with New Holland
on the west side of the state.
Men's Journal said,
that's a really cool idea,
we'd like to cover it.
So we did a tour all the way
to the Great American Beer
Festival in Denver, and we
had a pint with consumers
in every town along the way and
brought their stories to life.
And this is really
just a celebration.
Hey, what do you do
when you celebrate?
You drink a beer.
You raise a toast.
Well, that's what
this was meant to do,
and it led to tons and tons of
earned media and impressions
and storytelling.
I heard there was a sneaker
head in here, maybe one or two.
We did this in collaboration
with Eminem and brand Jordan.
Why did we do it?
Well, first and
foremost, we did it
to raise funds for
the Verses project
that's run by Michigan
State in inner city Detroit,
100% dedicated to
one thing, which
is what Eminem talked about that
he cares the most about, which
is the reason he is
where he is today
is because he actually
went back to school
and he learned how
to read and write.
If he couldn't read and write,
he wouldn't be who he is today.
And unfortunately, the
illiteracy rate in Detroit
is astoundingly high.
And if you can't
read and write, you
can't get a trades job, which
is what we're focused on, too.
So we raised a crazy amount of
money auctioning off 10 pairs.
And it's still one of the
most sought-after sneakers
right now.
The Jordan brand, we
stay in touch with them.
They're getting
calls all the time
from famous people who
are dying to get them,
and it just
continues to live on.
But the purpose was,
first and foremost,
to do a good thing
in our backyard.
And it allowed us to do it
and crazy amounts of coverage.
Another backyard partner, Chevy
Trucks, came to us and said,
you know, we don't know
why we didn't do this,
like, 25 years ago, but it
would make a lot of sense
for us to do a
truck with you guys
and make it the
ultimate work truck.
So this was a showcase truck.
It was at the auto
show in Detroit.
It was in LA.
It was at a couple
of other big shows,
and it's been a really, really,
really well-received concept
and idea.
So we're going to continue
to talk with one another
and see if we can actually
figure out if this makes sense
for a production run as well to
make the ultimate work truck.
You guys saw this
on the earned side--
again, collaborations
and partnerships
to tell meaningful stories.
We're also very
active in movies.
We love it.
This jacket-- the year this
movie came out, sold it out.
Sold that in the
US and in Europe.
Swear to God, that jacket.
That jacket hadn't moved
beyond its normal trajectory
for decades.
This movie comes out?
Bam.
It's unbelievable.
Just won an Oscar for
"Manchester by the Sea,"
again wearing our jacket
throughout that film.
And then we have a superhero
now, our first superhero.
Everyone know who this is?
Luke Cage.
Do you know what happened when
this show debuted on Netflix?
You guys had to laugh about
this, given who you are.
It crashed Netflix.
When this show debuted,
it crashed Netflix.
We're super excited
about the next season.
I guess they're pulling them all
together and some other cast.
My son would tell me what it is.
But he's going to be
wearing our new coat, which
is called Full Swing,
and he continues
to wear the Carhartt brand.
And then on the
paid front, I had
to put a plug-in for you guys.
[LAUGHTER]
This is from this morning.
Thankfully, Emily,
we're at the top.
That was good.
[LAUGHTER]
And I did not click on the ad.
I never do.
Please don't.
[LAUGHTER]
I know you guys want
us to, but I don't.
I always tell people at work,
don't click on the top one.
Go down to the one that's free.
Sorry.
We have enough people that
are clicking on the top one.
It's working really well.
But this is search
and discovery mode.
And for us, this is
one of those signals
that we love to look
at to see how people
are reacting to our work.
We see that people
will start searching
us more aggressively if our
work is really resonating.
And let me tell you, I've
got a lot of right brain.
I've got just enough
left brain to survive.
But there are a lot
of left-brainers
who want to see numbers
when we do stuff
and go, well, what do they do.
I love it when you guys can give
us that kind of information.
Like, oh my God, look
at all the search.
This happened and then
within a week or so--
it's powerful, so thank you.
Retail-- I talked
about where we are.
This is where we are.
For example, Field & Stream is
a Dick's Sporting Goods concept
in the outdoor industry.
I look at this as paid,
and the reason I do is--
see all that beautiful imagery?
And this is first and main.
This is right when you
walk in their store.
That's a billboard at
the point of decision.
So I look at those as
one the most valuable
spends we can make, because
I'm putting front and center
at that point of decision,
that zero moment of truth
that you guys
coined a while ago.
This is Boot Barn.
Have you ever heard
of a Boot Barn?
Anyone?
Oh, my God.
Somebody has.
But they're now publicly
traded, and they're
chasing the Western fashion
trend all over the country,
as well out of Southern
California, believe it or not,
not Texas.
And they are growing rapidly.
Tractor Supply.
Anyone know Tractor Supply?
Yeah, there we go.
So before I worked
at Carhartt, I
thought Tractor Supply was where
tractor supplies were sold,
I think.
And they still have
to overcome that name,
and they are an invaluable
partner, a great partner.
1,200 or 1,500 doors I
think they're up to now?
And we're bringing our
brand to life with them
in new ways, which is awesome.
Orchard Supply, a hardware
store on the West Coast,
owned by Lowe's.
They are beautiful.
You'd compare them to
downtown Home and Garden
if you recognize that local
retailer here as well.
And this is just an
example of how crazy it
can be with our mom
and pops, and this
is why they're important to us.
This is Hartville Hardware.
It's in central Ohio.
We have somewhere in the
neighborhood of, like, 10,000
square feet, which is bigger
than some of our retail stores.
We give millions of dollars
to this one hardware store.
We really need them to
figure out the internet.
Again, that's how
important it can be
for us as we think about this.
And then the trips
to those stores
have led to this
chain in Europe.
So in Ireland, there's
a hardware chain
called Woodie's, and we are
scaling shops all over Ireland
with this hardware chain,
where our brand is really
new in the workforce space.
So that is Carhartt.
So thank you for
staying through it all.
Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
BILL CRAWFORD: Thank you.
That was awesome.
I know just being in
Michigan and personally
living just outside
of Detroit, Carhartt's
been one of those brands that
really in the last-- call it
five to six years
has kind of come
into the millennial zeitgeist,
which is kind of a benefit.
But to hear you talk
about the authenticity
that you're not
necessarily trying
to do that-- it just
works out because you're
authentic without having to try.
TONY AMBROZA: Usually
you're only authentic
when you're not trying.
BILL CRAWFORD: Yeah, that's
a good way to put it.
Yeah.
TONY AMBROZA: No, but we have
an amazing story to tell.
We just needed to tell
it, quite honestly,
and that's what
we're all focused on.
BILL CRAWFORD: Yeah.
And so you touched
on this a little bit,
but the decision to put the
store in Midtown Detroit.
Can you tell me a
little bit about it?
Sounds like maybe there was
a backstory of some debate.
TONY AMBROZA: Well, there
was definitely debate.
I mean, you got a lot of
Detroiters, proud Detroiters
in the office.
People have been there
far longer than I.
And [INAUDIBLE],, who
runs our retail division,
has been with us now
for, I think, five years,
and he's been with great retail
brands throughout his career.
He found the space and he
really had the vision for it,
and he championed
it inside the halls.
Because Midtown-- what was
it, three plus years ago
when we signed the lease?
Somewhere in that neighborhood.
Midtown was still
kind of emerging.
And now, I mean, we're
seeing more and more
retail brands pop up all around
us, so it's been exciting.
We couldn't believe how people
really turned out for it, too.
It's doing really well,
far exceeding expectations.
BILL CRAWFORD: No, it's great.
My children destroyed it this
weekend, so sorry about that.
So I want to talk a little
bit about your career path.
It's been very cool.
I mean, there's a
lot of people in here
that work with all
different types of clients,
but I personally work with a
lot of retailers in the apparel
space.
So can you take us
through just your career?
I mean, we covered
it a little bit,
but I'd love to hear about the
path that led you to Carhartt.
TONY AMBROZA: Sure.
I mean, I'll try to be brief.
I can be pretty
boring really quickly.
I just knew that I wanted
to be a part of things
that people were
passionate about.
I wanted to work in
the marketing space.
I was an econ, poli
sci double major.
Most people in my space
didn't go to marketing.
They went and got
investment banking or law.
And I just knew I
wanted to be in a space
that people really cared about.
My worst nightmare
was trying to convince
people to buy a
brand or a product
that you really
didn't care about.
And I have always used
the example of-- not
to be negative on the
people who do that,
but I would never want to be
the head of a toilet paper brand
or something like that.
I always said I wanted to
be something that people
were passionate about.
And really, the key insight
for me was, and still is--
I mean, I'm really
passionate about things
that are related to the
life I grew up with.
And I grew up very
connected to sport
and very connected to a
blue collar way of life.
And that's really led my path.
And I had a really great
person, Al Rosenschein,
who was an alum of
the university college
I went to as an undergrad.
Basically, he gave
me that advice
while I was trying to
figure out what in the heck
I wanted to do.
And he said, just follow your
heart, follow your passion.
And that's what I've done
every step of the way,
and I've had a chance to
work for a sports agency,
representing Bulls
players when they
made their second run of three.
I worked for Planet
Hollywood when
everyone said that
that was going to be
the next concept of experience.
And then I went to
Nike and Under Armour.
And what I've found
every step of the way
is it's a heck of
a lot of fun when
you work for brands people
care a great deal about.
And that's what I have
with Carhartt as well.
BILL CRAWFORD: Very cool.
So Nike, Under Armour you've
been to a lot of big cities.
And then obviously, you're in
proximity to your hometown,
but you wind up in Dearborn,
in Carhartt, in Detroit.
How have you found
the fair cities?
TONY AMBROZA: Oh, great.
I mean, really, it's funny.
So when I moved to
Portland in '99,
Portland was not the
Portland you see today.
It's unbelievable
how that has changed.
It was pretty rough and rugged.
I lived off of Burnside,
and it was just a really,
really kind of-- it was turning,
but it was far from turning.
The Pearl District--
anybody been there?
You know where the
Pearl District is today?
It's basically
taken over Portland.
Anyway, so Portland
now is a shining star
example of a city
reborn, and Baltimore
was doing the same thing.
And then I moved here,
and now Detroit--
I mean, when I moved
here, I'll never forget
buying a place in Ann Arbor.
And the person we
were getting the loan
from at the bank was like,
everyone else is leaving;
why are you moving here?
And I looked at him.
I go, well, my
wife's right here.
Thanks a lot, buddy.
You know what I mean?
But I mean, it was
just that time.
There was a lot of
unsettled feelings.
And now you walk around,
and there's confidence,
there's pride, there's belief.
And there should be.
It's a great place to live.
Michigan is one of
the best kept secrets.
If it had a mountain,
we'd be overpopulated
because of the Great Lakes.
If we had a mountain to
go with those Great Lakes,
it would be over.
It would be over.
BILL CRAWFORD: That's fair.
So what you're
saying is, basically,
the next city you move to we
should start investing in,
because that's the better.
Got it.
TONY AMBROZA: There you go.
BILL CRAWFORD: So we
are almost out of time.
I've got one last question.
I know there's a lot of
folks in the audience
that, as we mentioned,
looked at your career path.
And it's very impressive.
If you had one piece of
advice to somebody aspiring
to follow a similar
path to yourself--
TONY AMBROZA: Well, like
I said at the beginning,
follow your passion, because
it will never be work.
And it hasn't.
And the number two thing
really is find people,
whether you work
for them or not,
who you can really,
really learn from.
And spend as much time
as you can soaking up
as much as you can
from those folks,
because I've had the great,
great fortune of having
some incredibly smart mentors
from the companies where I've
worked who've taught me a ton.
And I definitely wouldn't
be sitting here right
now talking to you guys this
way if it weren't for them.
And those are really the
two difference makers for me
along the way.
Lastly, I shouldn't
leave her out.
My wife has played a pretty
big role in this, too--
so an incredible
partner in crime
and being willing to
move the way we have.
BILL CRAWFORD: Yeah.
It's funny how that happens.
TONY AMBROZA: Yeah.
BILL CRAWFORD: Very cool.
Thank you very much, Tony.
I appreciate it.
A big round of applause
for Tony Ambroza.
TONY AMBROZA: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BILL CRAWFORD:
Thanks, everybody.